today I'm going to try and show that e
is an irrational number so e is this
fantastic number shall I just write it
it's
2.718 and it goes on and on and on and
on and on and it plays a role in just
about every aspect of physics it seems
to be everywhere in maths some
staggeringly important number what do
you call that amongst yourselves like
what do you just call it e or do you
call it the I call it e yeah it's
friendly and if someone at the pubs came
up to you and said hey Ed I know you
mathematicians and physicists have this
number called e and you all really like
her and it's important what actually is
a what would you say to them
oh defining ease the way I like to
Define e is it's the only number which
if I differentiate it I get back to
itself again so let me try and show you
so this is e but if I raise e to some
power x say so X could be one it could
be two so it could be e squared or it
could be three e cubed then if I plot
this as a function of X then it does
something like the following when x
equals zero e to the zero is one so it
begins at one and then as I increase X
this gross so e is roughly roughly three
so when x equals one this has got a
value of roughly three so when X is two
he's got a value roughly you know it's e
squared which is roughly 3 squared right
which is avoiding nine so you can see
it's rising up fairly rapidly now I
could ask this ask the question what's
the slope of this function right you
know if I as a slope we learn at school
is drawing a tangent at any point will
tell me the slope so that would be the
tangent at that point there and this
would be the tangent at that point there
and if I plot the tangent then I
actually get maybe the tangent should be
in red perhaps
I will basically get this
so that's the tangent imagine e to the x
is telling me about the distance I've
traveled as a function of time x here is
time so these are maybe seconds one
second two seconds three seconds
and then I decide actually it's not just
the distance I need it's the actual
velocity I need I need the rate of
change of the distance so that's the
slope
well the rate of change of the distance
is exactly the same function
okay so then I say well all right
actually what I really need I need the
acceleration I need to know how fast
this velocity is changing and if I do
the same again that's that's the slope
of the velocity
so it's the same curve again so the
velocity curve
the acceleration curve which has to be
in Black
it's exactly the same again so these are
this exponential function e to the x is
the only one that if I differentiate it
so if I work out D by DX of e to the X
then I get e to the X so it's the same
and then if I work out the next
differential of it
I get e to the X and it goes on and on
and on and on and that's the beauty of
this this particular function it that
all of its derivative or all of its
slopes match the actual function itself
why is that useful
I don't know where social in particular
I don't know what it is about that
property that means it plays such an
important role I mean in terms of
calculations it's it's it's it makes
things incredibly straightforward
because you can just do this but in
terms of its actual physical or
mathematical properties I'm not sure
what it is about that it means it
carries on forever
okay because the slope just keeps no
matter how far you go whereas other
functions will die off if you
differentiate them and the fact but the
fact it's keeping exactly the same
behavior is is one of the most
intriguing things so what we want to do
today is to demonstrate that this number
which goes up goes on and on and on and
on forever and ever and ever cannot be
represented as the a ratio of two
integers that's what an irrational
number is a rational number can always
be represented as the ratio of two
um integers a fraction a fraction in
fact they're made up of relative in
relative prime integers but they that's
just the technicality here we're going
to demonstrate that e cannot be done
that it's a proof due to Fourier that
absolutely brilliant mathematician I
think it's okay I think we'll be able to
do it okay so you're going to prove that
e is around yeah so it's so let's do the
proof e is irrational and I wish it was
my proof but it's not it's due to Joseph
Fourier I've been to his grave have you
yeah does doesn't mention this in it if
he did so many things it's in Paris it's
in the famous cemetery in Paris yeah
it's a cool grave he's he looks like
Voldemort because there's like a bust of
him on on it and he looks like Voldemort
okay okay anyway so let's let's do it so
what what do I mean by that I mean the E
cannot be represented as the by the
ratio of two into as a fraction as you
say so p and Q are known as relative
prime integers you know no matter how
big your integers are you will not be
able to represent e and so the proof
um is done in the following way you
assume that this isn't the case is it's
like James did with this square root of
showing the square root of 2 was
irrational and you assume that actually
you can work it and then you show
there's an inconsistency so you assume
that e can be represented as the ratio
of two integers and the one thing that
I've I've I'm hoping you will allow me
to write down is there is a
representation of e that I can write
down
so we can write that e has an infinite
series expansion it's one plus one over
one factorial another two factorial so
one over three factorial and it goes on
and on and on this is just common
knowledge this is common law you do this
at school and my daughter's done as
level she's she's been doing this does
this infinite series expansion of e
where three factorial just to remind
everyone is one times two times three
that's all it is so now what I want to
do is let me call this equation one all
right and I'll call this equation two so
I'm going to multiply
um equation 2 by Q factorial so there's
this Q here okay and so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to multiply this
expression
by Q factorial so the left hand side
becomes Q factorial times e
and that what does the right hand side
become well it becomes Q factorial plus
Q factorial over one factorial plus Q
factorial over 2 factorial Plus
Q factorial over Q factorial because I
eventually reached the q's term but then
there's a whole series of other terms
which for now let's just call them the
rest right there'll be a q factorial
over Q Plus One factorial and a q
factorial of a Q Plus two factorial it
just goes on for f but we've just we
know from our assumption that E equals p
over Q okay and that then means that Q
factorial times e
this is equal to what is that equal to
that's equal to Q minus 1 factorial
times Q times e because that's what Q
factorial is it's Q minus 1 factorial
times Q
but we always we already know that Q
times E equals p
so this is just
Q minus 1 factorial times p
so this is an integer
that's the key Point here Q minus one
factorial is just an integer p is just
an integer so the product of them is
just an integer so a q factorial times a
the left-hand side of this expression is
an integer okay
now let me look at the right hand side
of this expression well hopefully
you can be convinced that this thing
I've underlined it this is also an
integer Q factorial is just an integer
the SE Q factorial over one well that's
just an integer this is Q factorial over
2 fact factorial where the two's cancel
so this here is also an integer this is
an integer this is an integer this then
implies that the rest must be an integer
right I can't have an integer here an
integer here and have this not being an
integer otherwise it would imagine this
was a half
then I'd have an integer equals an
integer plus a half and that's not right
so so the rest must be an integer okay
so now I'm going to concentrate on the
rest right so what is the rest
well we also have that the rest let me
call it r
right for the rest
what is it it's Q factorial
because that's what I multiplied
everything by into and it's all these
other Expressions so it's
1 over Q Plus 1 factorial
plus 1 over
Q Plus 2 factorial
plus well let me do the next one Q Plus
3 factorial and it goes on forever and
ever like this okay I can now divide out
because you know this imagine Q was and
six this would be six factorial divided
by seven factorial so it would be one
over seven that would be all that's left
so this is just equal to 1 over Q Plus
One
plus 1 over and this is one over Q Plus
one times one over Q plus two
and this is just you get the idea one
over Q Plus one times one over Q Plus
two times one over Q plus three
plus dot dot dot okay and what I can do
I can simplify this I can bring out a 1
over Q Plus One
into the front and so this becomes one
plus one over Q plus two
plus one over
Q Plus two times Q plus three
okay and it goes on forever and ever and
ever so the key point now that I want to
make is that this this is what the rest
is it's exactly this but the the the
proof the the key thing of the proof now
comes in the fact that I know that this
has to be less than
the following well I keep the one over Q
Plus One
I keep the one now one over Q Plus 2 is
less than one over Q Plus one right
imagine Q was six again
then one over eight is less than one
over seven
similarly here this is less than 1 over
Q Plus 1 squared
right because this would be one over
eight times one over nine which is
clearly less than one over seven squared
and it just goes on like that right that
this is less than this
now this number here is less than one
because Q is Q is going to be bigger
than one this is less than one
there is a there's a beautiful little
proof due to Gauss and I'm going to
prove it for you so that we can then
just finish this off Gauss apparently
did this when it was about three right
all right so
so there's the following if x
some number is less than one then we
have the sum of N terms which is 1 plus
X
plus x squared plus x cubed plus up to x
to the N you can see what's going to
happen right my x's are going to be my 1
over Q Plus ones because these will be
the things that's less than one that's
where now let me do the following Gauss
did this
x times that right is equal to and then
it becomes I multiply the one I get the
X I get the x squared
I got the X cubed I'm going to get the
term that's x to the n and then if I
multiply x to the N by X I get one last
term which is X to the N Plus 1.
and I've shifted them all along so that
you can see that if I take one of these
away from the other
all these terms cancel
leaving me with just the first term and
the last term
so in particular it turns out that SN
into 1 minus X so I've just taken the
second term from the first term
equals well there's nothing to take away
from the one
their cancel their cancel their cancel
everything cancels that cancels and I'm
just left with that last term
1 minus x to the N plus one now the
series we've got is an infinite Series
this this series ends after n terms this
series goes on to Infinity so what
happens as n goes to Infinity as n goes
to Infinity because X is less than one x
to the N goes one goes to zero imagine a
half if I keep a half times a half is a
quarter times a half is an eight times a
half is a sixteenth it just gradually
goes towards zero so the X to the N plus
one goes to zero we're nearly there
Brady hang in there so this means that s
Infinity is one over one minus X so this
sum
I can now do because X is I'm just
replacing X by 1 over Q Plus One this s
Infinity for me becomes 1 over 1 minus 1
over Q Plus One
and that is equal to Q Plus 1 over Q
right that's just rearranging this so
if I come back to the all-important
remainder the rest this thing here
that I'm trying to bound remember I've
said it remember remember I've said it
must be an integer so the remainder I've
now I know it has to be less than one
over Q Plus One
Times by this sum well this is this sum
so it's times Q Plus 1 over Q
so the Q Plus ones cancel
so this is R must be less than 1 over Q
okay right we're nearly there now
because we already know
that R has to be positive because it's
just a sum of a positive positive terms
so R is greater than zero which means
that this for this proof to work
R is bounded between 0 and 1 upon q but
Q is bigger than one
so this is a fraction less than one IE R
is less than one
which means it cannot be an integer
therefore e cannot be represented as a
rational number so it has to be
irrational
all right
this episode has been brought to you by
kiwico get these boxes or crates as they
like to call them delivered right to
your home
then Marvel at your own engineering
prowess as You Follow the clear and
clever instructions to build all sorts
of ingenious devices I felt like this
occupied some fascinating Middle Ground
between well just plain fun and
something that's really educational I
was also really impressed by the design
and materials where was this when I was
a Youngster
when you order one of these crates you
can subscribe to all sorts of levels
depending on who's going to be doing the
building here I'm working on a tinker
crate that's suitable for anyone from
basically about nine years and up
everything you need is in the Box
batteries are included if they're part
of the build learn play and get 50 off
your first Crate by using the URL
kiwico.com number file give them a try I
really think you'll be impressed it's a
great family activity too if you happen
to be doing some home education
kiwico.com number file and here is my
finished Ballista
[Music]